a vancouver-based uh indigenous film
producer says he was treated like he was
trying to steal something after being
turned away from a red carpet at the
cannes film festival for wearing
traditional moccasins
yeah kelvin redfers a member of the
danae nation in the northwest
territories attended the festival with
five other indigenous filmmakers with
the backing of the indigenous screen
office and telephile and on sunday he
was invited to the screening of lay a
monday where he planned to wear a black
tuxedo along with a pair of moccasins
made by his sister
kelvin shared that the team he was
traveling with had explained that
despite the festival's ultra-strict
dress code there were allowances for
cultural formal wear yeah when he
arrived calvin explained to our friends
at global news that he arrived in
regular shoes as he didn't want to ruin
his moccasins but when he tried to swap
things escalated quickly with security
and that he was only able to proceed
when he changed back to his leather
shoes
i've been excited for
weeks to be able to bring my culture to
this red carpet event to be told are we
not reading any comments this isn't
welcome here
um
is something that stings it
but there is a good ending to kelvin's
story after having a chat with festival
directors they apologize for how he was
treated and had a positive discussion
then after being invited to a screening
of david cronenberg's crime of the
future uh kelvin wore his moccasins once
again and shared this
the first person who we bumped into
who saw the moccasins had the same
reaction nope nope nope
but the next person behind them who's a
little higher up saw who we were
knew the conversation that had been had
knew what we were wearing and said
yes
let them through
that was my favorite part of the
festival
ah that that's so great for him
it's you know canned film festival we
know there's so many rules involved you
can't even take a selfie tom hanks took
a selfie but one of the things that i
did notice is that uh people are were
allowed to wear sarees uh you're allowed
to wear a kilt so i don't think the
security knew what the moccasins were in
the first place and they're so strict
the security just follows all the rules
that are in place uh but you know one of
the great things about this because what
happened is also a new conversation
about people being more aware of
different cultures and their religions
and be you know understanding it and i'm
so glad that he had the opportunity to
actually be able to wear the moccasins
at the second time when he was invited
the next time in and they apologize so
it's a great outcome
yeah i agreed i think that the
the idea there that they were able to
have this conversation about it uh you
know they could teach uh can what it was
about that they were there for with the
moccasins uh to walk the red carpet and
that you know can could learn yeah they
could learn go okay well
we understand this now and yeah yes of
course invite him back the next day i
love that